nous on a des écoles s'ils nous disent
si j'apprends que mon stagiaire fait
plus de 35 heures par semaine je le
ferais arrêtez votre stage mais ça va
être dur un pote stagiaires barrière de
trouver du boulot et d'aller s'acheter
un appartement parce que moi en tout cas
dans le monde dans lequel je vis si je
travaille pas 80 heures par semaine il
ya très peu de chance que j'ai mon
appartement une résidence secondaire est
peut-être une autre après bien il ya un
paradoxe total entre la réalité
économique
la violence du marché du travail la
violence du monde dans lequel on vit ce
qu'on raconte à la jeune génération et
qui a aussi droit d'être en colère donc
voilà c'est s'il ya une forme de colère
dans cette génération dans laquelle je
suis juste avant mais je la comprends et
je la ressens là moi je pense à la
génération des parents qu'est-ce que
c'était royal alors que ça vous choque
que c'est pourri c'est vrai que le
stagiaire change ou des vieux lait bio
qu'on met à mon époque entre les
stagiaires le but est de se faire
remarquer et d'en faire le plus possible
dans un pub on ne comptait pas ses
heures cette déclaration la afe a fait
scandale est ce que vous comprenez
bernard je ne vois pas pourquoi
effectivement ça fait scandale parce que
c'est toujours comme ça va les
stagiaires c'est ça a toujours été ça
sera toujours est évidemment toujours
l'idée c'est de de faire du buzz
évidemment pour se faire remarquer se
faire engager quelque part moi j'ai
trouvé sa sortie honteuse r c'est
totalement déplacé les stagiaires c'est
pas des esclaves du travail
ça à considérer les jeunes adultes comme
des fainéants mais on n'a pas su le
normand sa considérer les hommes ou les
femmes d'entreprise comme des gens qui
mobilise ses nouveaux venus sur le monde
du travail a bossé d'autant plus je
trouve ça un peu déplacé
on peut entendre qu'une entreprise rob
lettre qu'il n'est pas une voilà qui est
pas une volonté de travailler un peu
plus
par semaine
salariés mais elle reproche aux gens de
ne pas vouloir travailler en même temps
elle veut pas payer des gens je suis
désolé dans l'entretien et dis moi
j'aime pas les alternants tu m'étonnes
les alternances ça coûte de l'argent les
stagiaires c'est gratuit elles veulent
les exploiter les faire travailler 80 80
heures par semaine c'est pas une manière
de gérer une entreprise en touriste
aussi de l'humain est une des clés du
succès d'une entreprise c'est que les
gens aient des bonnes conditions de
travail et soient bien payés parce
qu'elle dit c'est n'importe quoi c'est
cesser enfin c'est pas comme ça qu'on
gère une boîte alors un stage de moins
de quatre mois est gratuit je crois à
vérifier mais je voulais qu un stage de
plus de quatre mois est obligatoirement
payant mais ça vient c'est rien mais je
remets pas en cause c'est je pense que
ces propos peut-être ont mal été dit
mais je pense en entrepreneur tu
entrepreneurs chien entrepreneuse que en
fait qu'elle voulait dire c'est juste
que aujourd'hui dans le monde du travail
malheureusement c'est pas aussi facile
et il faut travailler travailler parce
que c'est très très dur et il faut
peut-être expliquer aux jeunes que le
travail c'est la base de la réussite
alors attention attention oui il faut
travailler à
l'étranger 93 de
ses très mal exprimé
oui c'était très maladroite mais en soit
ce qu'elle a voulu jim moi j'ai compris
comme ça c'était aussi de dire attention
c'est pas si facile moi j'ai une
entreprise elle a dit sa régie
d'entreprise chez d'entreprise et je ne
peux pas travailler 35 heures et c'est
vrai qu'aux jeunes il faut leur dire
aussi la vérité elle est chef
d'entreprise et voilà et c'est pas comme
ça pas moi ça m'énerve en fait cette
dame hélène start-ups et des gens qui
font des levées de fonds qui vivent dans
un monde fictif avec de l'argent fictif
ou non si tu veux des gens qui
travaillent pour toi qui travaille
beaucoup faut les payer les rémunérés à
leur juste valeur je suis ne peut pas
exploiter des stagiaires et les payer
que d'allumer l'isère c'est ça marche
pas sa belle et le morro moi je trouve
que là on la comprend mal cm2 les 80
heures c'est elle qui les fait et elle
dit qu en fait si on habitue très jeune
quelqu'un à dire il faut absolument pas
déplacé des dalles et dépasser les 35
heures c'est pas la réalité du monde du
travail ça c'est ce qu'a dit après on
peut en débattre mais on lui fait un
mauvais procès parce que c'est le 4e
valeur c'est elle qui les fait donc
après il faudra faire attention
évidemment nous parler hier les gens il
ya des pour les réseaux se sont
déchaînés
et créer les 80 heures c'est elle qui on
est grand temps que que quand on
commence un boulot même si on est voilà
il ya la loi et ce qu'on a on peut pas
regretté qu' il n'y ait pas un emprunt
ou une volonté à plus d un enthousiame
bien sûr je vois la corde mais jamais
entre inciter la jeunesse à travailler
plus pour gagner plus et à ne pas
compter ses heures il ya une différence
entre ce que guillaume des métiers de
l'exploitation qui sorte d'esclavagé
moderne
c'est inaudible en fait mais vous on
peut pas parler d' esclavage pour sa fin
moi j'ai été sage erp comme je pense
beaucoup ici mais je bossais comme une
malade et j'ai pu s'oxyder de me lever
le matin et de partir tard le soir et de
travailler et de quasiment pas être
payés voire pas du tout parce que je me
disais à la clé je vais montrer de quoi
je suis capable et je trouvais ça génial
et je trouve ça génial ce qu'elle dit
cette femme franchement faut arrêter
d'être choqué le génial
c'est bien que des gens qui disent
vraiment ce qu'ils pensent parce que la
vérité c'est que dans les entreprises
maintenant il faut qu'ils aient des
jeunes stagiaires qui puisse bosser
comme des oufs et ensuite justement
mélangeons pas tout parce qu'il ya aussi
des preuves de cela tu veux dire
stagiaires de 80 heures parfois
vous ayez que vous ayez des alternants
les chefs d'entreprise et je suis un
chef d'entreprise prennent des
alternants qu'ils peuvent gagner entre
1000 milles 2300 euros pour rentrer dans
le monde du travail et puis demain
pérenniser leur travail et les engager
c'est tout à fait autre chose mais vous
pas pouvez pas demander un stagiaire
bénévoles en plus le problème tient à
saint prime de génération à la une
trentaine d'années elle aurait 50 ans
elle aurait 50 ans il ya trente ans et
le monde du travail n'est pas le même il
faut vivre avec son temps donc
stagiaires à 80 heures c'est il nous
disait
hier que d'employer ça s'est passé